ratatouille
it's a peasant dish are you sure you
want to serve this to eagle
[Music]
what i am making ratatouille well how
would you prepare it
it must be joking
let's learn english with one of my
favorite disney films all about cooking
and paris ratatouille so the clips that
we've chosen for you today
are really great for learning english to
describe food and
for use in formal situations so we're
gonna jump right into that but quickly
before we do
if you're new here every single week
make fun lessons just like this one
so that you can understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles just like our friend gills
who says that watching our videos every
single day is helping him to improve his
accent in english so we're gonna help
you improve your english a ton too
it's really simple hit that subscribe
button and the bell down below and you
won't miss a single one of our new
[Music]
lessons
i brought you something to ah no no no
no no
spit that out right now ugh i have got
to teach you about food
close your eyes now take a bite
of this no no no don't just
hork it down here
that chew it slowly only think about the
taste
creamy salty sweet and oaky nuttiness
you detect that oh i'm detecting
nuttiness
close your eyes now taste this
a whole different thing right sweet
crisp
slight tang on the finish okay now
try them together okay
i think i'm getting a little something
there
it might be the nuttiness see could be
the tang
that's it now imagine every great taste
in the world being combined into
infinite combinations
taste that no one has tried yet
discoveries to be made
[Music]
you lost me again
i brought you something to ah no no no
no no
spit that out right now oh i have got to
teach you about food
did you notice he said have got instead
of just have
this is just how some people say it and
there's no change in meaning
what's more important is actually the
tone used in speech we often contract
words
have got becomes gotta cannot becomes
can however when we are surprised angry
or have another emotion that makes us
want to emphasize what we say
we normally don't use contracted forms
so
note the difference in you can't use
your phone in class versus
you cannot use your phone in class
same in i gotta go now versus i have got
to go now
now take a bite of this
in the phrase take a bite we can see one
instance of using take
plus a plus a noun we use many of these
phrases in everyday speech
yes girly now
make a wish and take a bite
now if you take a bite of something you
take a small piece of food
into your mouth maybe you want to try
something your friend is eating
which of these would you use can i take
a bite of that
can i have a bite of that can i bite
that
so here we change it from take to have
let's see some other examples where this
happens
are you hungry zazu perhaps
we could have a bite together
climb aboard boys taffy will take us to
the lower level and you can have a bite
to eat
no no no don't just hork it down
to hork something down means to eat
something really quickly
so remy's saying that he should savor
the flavors of the food
not just quickly swallow them chew it
slowly
only think about the taste when you eat
you chew your food several times before
swallowing
example this meat's so tough i can
hardly chew it
the other word is taste we see this word
being used as a noun and a verb in this
clip
food has taste meaning it has flavor to
taste is the action of feeling that
flavor
oh you gotta taste this this is
oh it's got this kind of nice burning
melty it's not really a smoky taste it's
a certain oh
it's kind of like a don't you think
what would you call that flavor
lightning
yeah it's lightningy
creamy salty sweet and oaky nuttiness
you detect that oh i'm detecting
nuttiness
close your eyes when describing food
it's really common that we turn
nouns into adjectives by adding a y at
the end of the noun
so something with cream is creamy
something with salt is salty
then to describe these qualities of food
as a noun we add the suffix n-e-s-s
to the end of some words we might say
the creaminess
and saltiness of cheese when he says
oaky nuttiness he's applying both those
modifications to those words
what he means is that the food has a
flavor of oak nuts
acorns learning how to modify words like
this is really useful if you like
cooking or wine for example
it's a bold flavor fruity a little
earthy
what do you think fruity and delicious
yeah
then we have a joke here that you might
have missed this is done with a play on
words
he says i'm detecting nuttiness to
detect means to notice something
the double entendre comes with the word
nuttiness literally we can understand
that he notices
that nutty flavor however the humor is
that we say someone is nuts or nutty
when we think they are crazy so he is
joking that remy seems crazy
he's nuts ain't no need to watch where
i'm going
now taste this a whole different thing
right
sweet crisp slight tang on the finish
okay which of the images below shows a
food that is crispy
he also says the food has a tang which
is taste or smell that is pleasantly
strong or
sharp for example recipes might add some
citrus fruit to give the food some tang
example this sauce is so tangy and
delicious
okay now try them together
okay i think i'm getting a little
something there
in this movie remy is passionate about
combining different flavors to create
something new
oh gusto was right oh
yeah oh amazing
each flavor was totally unique
but combine one flavor with another
and something new was created
we saw the meaning of taste before to
try has a similar meaning
it means to put a piece of food in your
mouth and taste it
you try food to see if you like it or if
you'd rather not have any more food
what try this it's better
i think i'm getting a little something
there
it might be the nuttiness see could be
the tang
that's it now imagine every great taste
in the world being combined into
infinite combinations
taste that no one has tried yet
discoveries to be made
you lost me again we say
you lost me to mean now i don't
understand what you mean
if sangeef is good guy who will crush
man's skull like sparrow's egg between
ties and i say zangief you are bad guy
but this does not mean you're bad guy
[Applause]
right i'm sorry i just you lost me there
which of the options below doesn't mean
i understand
gotcha copy that i'm following
[Music]
right all of these can be used as
alternatives to i understand
now learning native expressions like
this is crucial to being able to
understand
fast english along with having correct
pronunciation
and knowing about connected speech which
is how natives cut and connect our words
and cultural context which helps you to
understand all the jokes
now in our three part master class we
teach you about all three
so that you can understand natives at
any speed
so you can learn more and sign up for
that machine up here or down description
below
and it's absolutely free so you have
nothing to lose
now let's watch the next clip
[Music]
i can't remember the last time i asked a
waiter to give my compliments to the
chef
and now i find myself in the
extraordinary position of having my way
to
be the chef thanks but i'm just your
waiter tonight
then who do i thank for the meal uh
excuse me a minute
[Music]
you must be the chef i wish to meet the
chef you will have to wait
until all the other customers have gone
so be it
[Music]
at first ego thinks it's a joke but as
linguine
explains ego's smile disappears
the following day his review appears
last night i experienced something new
an extraordinary meal from a singularly
unexpected source to say that both the
meal and its maker have challenged my
preconceptions about fine cooking
is a gross understatement they have
rocked me to my core in the past
i have made no secret of my disdain for
chef gusto's famous motto
anyone can cook not everyone can
become a great artist but a great artist
can come from anywhere it is difficult
to imagine
more humble origins than those of the
genius now cooking at
gustos who is in this critic's opinion
nothing less than the finest chef in
france
i will be returning to gusto soon hungry
for more
ratatouille it's a peasant dish although
many associated the word ratatouille
with the name of this movie
it actually comes from the name of a
traditional french dish making a play on
words with the name of this recipe and
the animal
we say dish to refer to a food container
as in the picture
or a type of food that is cooked in a
particular way and is served as a part
of a meal spaghetti all pomodoro is a
traditional italian dish for example
peasant is a word that in pastimes was
used to refer to poor families
what she means here is that ratatouille
is not a fine or sophisticated dish
rather it is a food that people eat in
context of poverty
[Music]
are you sure you want to serve this to
ego
to serve means to give someone food or
drink especially as a part of a meal
or in a restaurant bar etc
we say that someone must be joking when
we're surprised about what someone is
doing
we'll see more about how the word must
is used here in a few moments
i can't remember the last time i asked a
waiter to give my compliments to the
chef
a compliment is a remark that shows you
admire someone or something
we commonly use this also as a verb
there's a customer who wants to
compliment the chef
shall i let him in sure i love this part
come on in hi
richard actually i'm not here to
compliment the chef
oh that's okay night when people come
back to compliment the chef
like i have nothing better to do he says
it as a phrase
to give someone a compliment we also
sometimes say to pay someone a
compliment
you must be the you probably know
that must in a general way
could be used as a stronger version of
have to when talking about an obligation
example all passengers must wear seat
belts
however when you're very sure about
something especially because there's
evidence
you can say must as seen in this clip
the character here is sure he is the
chef
let's see two examples when must is used
in this way
[Music]
you must be the dragon warrior and you
must be kai my wife and i
we were your biggest fans oh you're a
man of good taste
[Laughter]
now you must be tired hungry uh-huh
so be it this is an expression of
acceptance or resignation
cornell is a good school and i want to
better myself through higher education
if it makes andy angry so be it
we have only one choice we must leave
pride rock
we're not going anywhere then you have
sentenced us to death
then so be it you can't do that i am the
king i can do whatever i want
if you were last night i experienced
something new an extraordinary meal
from a singularly unexpected source
he describes the meal as extraordinary
this is another
word for good which we included in this
lesson where we go through 50 different
ways to say this adjective
now the critic here ego is using many
sophisticated words
and singularly is one of them we use
this to mean something is in a way that
is very
noticeable or unusual example he is
singularly qualified for the job
source to say that both the meal
and its maker have challenged my
preconceptions about fine cooking
is a gross understatement
if something we say is an understatement
it means it is not strong enough to
express how good
bad impressive etc something really is
gross in this case intensifies the
meaning of this word
so we're actually going to do this yes
we are let me just give this guy my keys
and
and we'll go great great understatement
like in the clip you can collocate this
word with a sentence that starts with to
say
example to say the movie was bad is an
understatement
other terms for fine cooking or dining
are gourmet food and high class cuisine
this would be the opposite of what was
referred to earlier in the clips as a
peasant dish or
peasant food they have rocked me
to my core in the past
i have made no secret of my disdain for
chef gusto's famous motto
anyone can cook if something
rocks you to your core it affects you in
a very profound way
or it provides a big revelation you can
also say this to describe something
that's very surprising to you
disdain is a formal synonym for dislike
he says he's made
no secret of that meaning he's always
said publicly that he didn't agree with
chef gusteau's motto
governing his shoes and governing his
prioritizing i made no secret of the
fact the crime bill was my top priority
well then congratulations it's only
taken you three years to put together
crime prevention legislation that has no
hope of preventing crime
a motto is a short sentence or phrase
that expresses the belief of a person
or gives a rule on how to behave example
the school's motto was work hard and
play hard
it is difficult to imagine more humble
origins than those of the genius now
cooking at
gustos who is in this critic's opinion
nothing less than the finest chef
in france i will be returning to gusto
soon hungry for more
by using the expression nothing less
than he's emphasizing how great a chef
he
is another expression with a similar
meaning is nothing short of
which describes something extreme either
good or bad
example the party was nothing short of a
[Music]
disaster
i will be returning to gusto soon hungry
for more it was a great night
the happiest of my life but the only
thing predictable about life
is its unpredictability well we had to
let skinner and the health inspector
lose
and of course they ratted us out the
food didn't matter
once it got out there were rats in the
kitchen oh man
the restaurant was closed and ego lost
his job
and his credibility but don't feel too
bad for him
he's doing very well as a small business
investor he seems very happy
[Music]
i will be returning to gusto soon hungry
for more it was a great night
the happiest of my life many times some
great pronunciation sites only require
paying a little attention to get them
so every now and then try listening for
the subtle details of native speech
did you notice that the g in great isn't
pronounced as such
it was a great night it actually sounds
like a k
in this example the same happens you
know dad chandler is one of ross's very
best friends
now ross sure is a great guy also
aspects of linking aren't always easy to
notice
but again you need to focus a bit on how
they're said in native speech
in this case notice the weakening of of
which sounds like
uh and it connects with the preceding
word happiest of my life
hey if you're enjoying this lesson with
ratatouille then i know you're going to
love this other one we made with another
one of my disney favorites
up so you can watch that by clicking up
here or down the description below
after you finish this lesson well we
had to let skinner and the health
inspector loose and of course they
ratted us out
as you can see here they tied and locked
up skinner and a health inspector
but then they had to let them loose
meaning they set them free
we use this expression all the time but
it's a funny choice for remy
to rat someone out means to tell someone
in authority about something wrong that
someone has done do this again
don't you ever never do this again come
here
you've been ratted out boys
the food didn't matter once it got out
there were rats in the kitchen
oh man the restaurant was closed if a
secret gets out
everybody suddenly knows about it
example it got out that the boss is
dating one of the employees
[Music]
close your eyes now take a bite
of this no no no don't just
hork it down and chew it
slowly creamy salty sweet
and oaky nuttiness you detect that oh
i'm detecting nuttiness close your eyes
now taste this
a whole different thing right sweet
crisp
slight tang on the finish
a little okay there it might be the
nuttiness
see could be the tang that's it now
imagine every great taste in the world
being combined into
infinite combinations taste that no one
has tried yet discoveries to be made
[Music]
it's a peasant dish are you sure you
want to serve this to eagle
what i am making ratatouille well how
would you prepare it
ratatouille they must be joking
[Music]
i can't remember the last time i asked a
waiter to give my compliments to the
chef
thanks but i'm just your waiter tonight
then who do i thank for the meal uh
excuse me a minute
you must be the wish to meet the chef
you will have to wait
until all the other customers have gone
so be it
at first ego thinks it's a joke but as
linguine
explains ego's smile disappears
the following day his review appears
last night i experienced something new
an extraordinary meal from a singularly
unexpected source
to say that both the meal and its maker
have challenged my preconceptions about
fine cooking
is a gross understatement
they have rocked me to my core
in the past i have made no secret of my
disdain for chef gusto's famous motto
anyone can cook
anyone can cook but i realize
only now do i truly understand
what he meant it is difficult to imagine
more humble origins than those of the
genius now cooking at
gustos who is in this critic's opinion
nothing less than the finest chef in
france
i will be returning to gusto soon
it was a great night but the only thing
predictable about life
is its unpredictability well we had to
let skinner and the health inspector
lose
and of course they ratted us out once it
got out there were rats in the kitchen
oh man the restaurant was closed and ego
lost
his job and his credibility
but don't feel too bad for him he's
doing very well as a small business
investor
[Music]
gotta go come on what did the la cruz
always say
seize your moment show me what you got
muchacho i'll be your first audience
miguel abuelita what are you doing here
um you leave my grandson alone tonya
please
i will just get in the shine i know your
tricks mariachi what did he say to you
he was just showing me his guitar